l'anno scorso l'amministrazione comunale
ha proposto alla scuola media parini di
eleggere il consiglio comunale dei
ragazzi
le elezioni sono state fatte così ogni
classe ha eletto quattro rappresentanti
due ragazze e due ragazzi una specie di
primarie i rappresentanti delle classi
riuniti hanno formato le liste erano tre
gli facevo parte di una di queste ogni
lista ha redatto il suo programma ha
scelto il proprio simbolo e il candidato
sindaco
i programmi sono stati esposti a tutti
gli studenti riuniti nell'aula magna
tutti gli alunni della scuola hanno
votato è stata votata la mia lista e io
sono stato eletto sindaco come sindaco
rappresenta tutti
come sindaco rappresenta tutti i miei
compagni anche le mie parole di oggi
esprimono le opinioni dei miei compagni
andrea di via volta
cos'è miguel nato all'avana che avete in
via cadorna francesco divertenti david
viene dal brasile e abita in via milano
pietro di via ferrari stefan viene da
romania e abita camerlata andrea di via
xx settembre
nato in ecuador vivendi apesi silvia di
via valeggio luca dive rezzonico non
passano in carli tutti ma era per dire
che abbiamo parlato insieme di quello
che vi dirò
noi viviamo la città in due modi
muovendoci e stando fermi muovendo c la
maggior parte di volte le guardiamo la
città percorrendo la andrebbe strada
como non è proprio piacevole è vero che
ci sono edifici e palazzi belli
restiamo sempre incuriositi da tante
cose ma i percorsi non sono continui non
scorrono bene sono sempre interrotti a
brevi pezzetti uno non riesce a prendere
un bel camminare tranquillo continuo
magari a guardare un po per aria sembra
che ci siano sempre interruzioni
manca la continuità bisognerebbe curare
i percorsi dei pedoni che avrebbero poi
proseguire anche fuori dal centro
storico invece è tutto spezzettato delle
attese ai semafori dalle macchine che
ripartono accelerano dai pavimenti che
cambiano un bel tratto di percorso
pedonale continuo e marciapiede vicino i
parcheggi dell'area che mi hanno detto
era dello zoo in via sant'elia
ecco lì è bello camminare tra gli alberi
e protetti dalla sempre bassa anche il
parco vicino è molto bello e tenuto bene
quando un pulp e tenuto bene nessuno il
loro vino
forse per questo che molti parchi molti
parchi tenuti male sono anche rovinati
da vandalismi vorremmo una città dove le
piste ciclabili ci fossero davvero non
quei piccoli tratti come in via cadorna
davanti conservatorio
c'è un tratto ciclabile lungo 25 metri
che non si sa da dove venga da dove vada
le piste ciclabili sono belle quando
scorrono sicure continue e non solo
delle trappole dove ci vuole più
attenzione a restare
belli che pedalare sulle ciclabili
dovrebbero poter andare anche i bambini
senza la sorveglianza dei genitori
un bel tratto di ciclabile potrebbe
essere quello di viale cavallotti viale
varese tra le bici e le automobili c'è
un filare di alberi che toglie un po di
smog e di confusione della strada forse
sarebbe meglio che le piste ciclabili
non ci fossero affatto ma che ovunque si
potessero andare in bici le auto
dovrebbero avere un loro itinerario
separato separato da un po di alberi per
esempio vorrei salire sulla montagna
della spina verde o di brunate
direttamente dalla città passeggiando
con i miei amici per guardare con loro
il bosco incontrare un cinghiale
guardare i piatti dall'alto vorrei
salire sulle mura e fare il giro
scendendo al lago come una volta quando
il percorso e mezzo agli alberi
l'ho visto sul libro che racconta come
era la città quando hanno costruito il
teatro sociale anche due o tre volte di
seguito così potrai vedere la città da
sopra stando fermi gli spazi a como per
la gente e soprattutto per i ragazzi
sono pochi voglio dire gli spazi dove
vien voglia di fermarsi di parlare di
stare anche nel centro storico le strade
si restringono per far posto ai tavolini
del bar uno per fermarsi un attimo
dovrebbe sedersi a un bar ordinare
qualcosa
così i due ragazzi siamo esclusi siamo
esclusi anche da tutte queste vetrine
una dietro l'altra per chilometri di
strade pedonali
noi ragazzi le vetrine le guardiano le
guardiamo poco fino a fino a che non
siamo assurdi assorbiti dai gusti dei
grandi
ci vorrebbero degli spazi dove ci sono
dei muretti delle banche per sedersi
magari in posizioni dove è bello
guardare quello che succede intorno
piazza del duomo è bella anche la piazza
che sta dietro ma uno dove si mette dove
si siede quando mettono le casette di
legno per natale sotto al broletto e si
forma un piano unico
sembra che stare sotto il portico sia
molto più bello un posto bello per
fermarsi ma normalmente quando c'è quel
buco bisogna scendere nessuno ci va
vorrei la città dove ci sono molti più
parchi giardini dove si possono guardare
le piante perché lì ci si sente più
liberi
e si possa anche correre c'è uno spazio
verde vicino alla chiesa di sant'antonio
in via rezzonico perché nessuno lo usa
questa parte di città e quasi senza un
minimo di verde o di un porto per
sedersi si potrebbe fare la piccola rea
per stare un parco
anche la chiesa è un peccato che sia un
negozio bisognerebbe che fosse almeno un
luogo pubblico per trovarsi per fare
insieme qualcosa vorrei una città con i
portici dove poter stare anche quando
piove qui a como
piove molto e ci vogliono posti al
coperto ho visto delle stampe antiche di
piazza cavour era tutta circondata da
portici è vero ci sono anche adesso
sotto l'hotel barchette edificio dopo i
portici di via plinio ma tramezzini e
negozi non si può proprio stare
vorrei poterle toccare l'acqua del lago
e non solo guardare dal parapetto
vorrei che ci fossero dei battelli fermi
per poterci salire a vedere come
funzionano
uno spazio verde tutto e recuperare la
nottata dal treno è il vecchio scalo
ferroviario che si trova che si trova
sopra la via regina tra sant'abbondio e
la stazione di como san giovanni
serviva una volta ma oggi abbandonato è
invaso da piante infestanti è un
percorso lunghissimo sono più di 800
metri di lunghezza
ci sono ancora i binari ma sono quasi
sepolti dalla vegetazione
siamo stati a vedere questo posto faceva
anche un po paura perché si capiva che
ha degli edifici abbandonati chi vive
della gente che la destina in difficoltà
sarebbe bellissimo mettere a posto
questo grande spazio di utilizzato
propongo di farci innanzitutto delle
grandi pareti sono i quali tutti quelli
che hanno voglia di fare i graffitari
possono disegnare a loro piacimento i
loro dipinti saranno visti bene da chi
passa con il treno venendo anche da
lontano o dall'estero
poi fare un grande parco delle ferrovie
ma esponendo sui binari morti locomotive
e vagoni facendo vedere anche come sono
fatti nei meccanismi
sarebbe bello poterci girare e capire
come davvero funzionano i treni ruote
carrelli freni sospensioni respingenti
pantografi tutto circondato dal verde un
parco appunto naturalmente troviamo
anche una casa
era per la gente che adesso dorme lì
clandestinamente non credo che io i miei
amici
vogliamo delle cose speciali e
straordinarie per le cose strane e ci
sono già garda la disneyland di jacopa
klepis da sci
i villaggi turistici 3 tutti prima o poi
finiamo per andare
non ci bastano giochi per bambini dietro
dietro a recinti con scivoli castello
arrampicate che stancano dopo cinque
minuti di 20 utilizzare i giochi divisi
per età lo vogliamo stare serve isolate
dalla città vera quello che può
interessare noi deve piacere anche gli
adulti che devono poter correre anche
loro sulle mura come i bambini più
piccoli come è la città bella che
dovrebbe essere solo trattata meglio le
cose che ci sono vanno verso e posto e
tenute bene bisogna riuscire a capire
come farle funzionare stando bene a
tutti
la città che vorrei esiste già lo
bisogna inventare una nuova
bisogna solo ravvivarla guardandola con
gli occhi nuovi
anche con gli occhi di noi ragazzi